The Joe Rogan Experience how the [__]
does one go from playing in Nirvana and
Soundgarden to being a soldier
um it's it's a longer story I don't know
how I want to hear it how long an answer
you want we got a plenty of time okay
um
so
I guess being a professional rock
musician was something I kind of fell
into it wasn't something that I like had
a dream of you know it's like oh I'm
gonna be
you know I love playing in bands I love
playing music but it was like at this
punk rock level where
you're never going to make a living at
it you know it's just something fun to
do
and then uh started playing with Nirvana
and even at that levels you know still
not making money from it but you know
touring was it the early days of Nirvana
yeah yeah so Nirvana wasn't worldwide
not at that point no
um there were
even on the Seattle level like one of
the the smaller bands you know like
there's bands like mud honey and
Soundgarden that were
better known than Nirvana was at the
time and you played for Soundgarden too
which is also hilarious
and when when did you like so you're in
in the beginning so did you just have
did you have friction with the band like
why did you wind up leaving
so uh with Nirvana is just
I guess initially like when I came on
board
like Kurt wanted a second guitar player
for the live show basically like uh have
a heavier sound live take some of the
guitar playing responsibility off him so
he could concentrate on vocals like that
kind of thing
and initially like I thought I was going
to be able to contribute to the band
creatively
and then it got to the point where I
realized that wasn't going to happen and
the same thing happened with Chad the
drummer I think
and it was like everyone in the band
including myself was like very
poor communicators like a lot of passive
aggression and
you know I mean we were kids you know
probably at the time 20 I think and
yeah I did I just I wasn't equipped for
it and uh
became more and more unhappy with the
situation and then ended up leaving so
was it that like when you try to put
creative input in it would get shut down
or they weren't interested or Kurt
wasn't interested yeah so like on the
rare time
where we actually rehearsed as a band
which was not a lot
um Kurt would kind of half-heartedly
like hey who has ideas and like I'd
throw a couple ideas out and then Chad
like a very accomplished musician in his
own right would throw some ideas out and
then it'd just kind of be glossed over
and like
okay here's the new song I wrote you
know and start learning that so it was
very
uh egocentric cursory you know it's like
he he kind of like threw it out there
but then it wasn't going to go anywhere
and so
um did you so you went for Nirvana first
and then the sound garden yeah like I
left we did a US tour like the First
full U.S tour that Nirvana did and
88 or 89 I can't remember what year it
was but I think it was still the 80s
and like I I left at the end of that
tour like okay I'm I'm done like nice
little four-way foray into into rock and
roll but I'm gonna do something else and
when I got home
um I was planning on going trekking in
the Himalayas like really yeah that was
the next that was the next thing it's
like okay this was a nice diversion
but uh I'm gonna kind of fulfill this
dream I've had since I was a kid of like
trekking in the Himalayas so I like I
went to Metzger's maps in Seattle and
was buying maps of the Himalaya of Nepal
and Tibet and all this stuff and like
getting gear sorted and that's what I
was gonna do
and then at some point that summer
or fall I can't remember what time of
year it was Into Summer
um Kim from Soundgarden called me and uh
was like Hey
hero the their bass player then like
quit do you want to audition for the
band
I was like you know at that point like
Soundgarden was my favorite Seattle band
like hands down and it was like okay
you know fully not believing I'd ever
get chosen
and then you did yeah
and how did that end
uh I got fired
what happened
um it's complicated but I think at the
end of the day
um
I I wasn't getting along with Chris that
well the singer
and you know obviously you know who's
gonna go right yeah it was me yeah
so how does that translate into becoming
a soldier
uh I mean there's more
there's there's more to the story than
that because there was still like
I basically like getting fired from
Soundgarden like put me in a pretty bad
tailspin
um
it I mean it was a a rough hatch in my
life for sure
and so
in order to kind of
uh
cut this tail spin off like I've I had
to do something radical and what I did
was ended up moving to New York
and so
I mean there's more to the story than
that
um
but moved to New York like basically you
know I grew up in rural Western
Washington like so it's kind of polar
opposite to what I what my experience
was like got a job in a warehouse got an
apartment
and kind of started my New York Life and
did that for a couple of years what was
your plan when you moved to New York you
just wanted to try it experience life in
the city I think the main plan was like
like get out of this funk that I was in
you know how old were you at the time 21
22 maybe so just young guy trying to
figure out life yeah I mean like the
sound garden thing
getting fired from Soundgarden like it
broke my heart it was
it was a bad spot for me and uh
because I love that band and it was it
wasn't about you know I never thought
they would get as big as they did
honestly it kind of surprised me when
they did because yeah they're a great
band but I think I always thought they
were a little too quirky to be
huge despite you know the Chris Factor
like you know this
genetically engineered rock star you
know
um but I always thought they're a little
too weird to be have like mainstream
success which was fine with me I thought
they'd be like like a big Indie band
like Sonic Youth or Butthole Surfers
like that level you know
and um but it was more like I just love
that band and I love playing with them
and like
having that taken away yeah it really it
[__] me up for a bit so what happened
so during this period 1993
um I I started I guess crafting the next
the next chapter right for me
and I'd always been really intrigued by
the military
uh my grandfather both my grandfathers
were World War II vets
um
so my maternal grandfather was a tank
commander in World War II
and he was kind of my
introduction to like military stuff you
know and I'm a little kid so I'm
intrigued by it like you know oh tank
commander that's cool
like he on D-Day he was in E4 Corporal
like Gunner on a Sherman tank on VE Day
his unit had made it all the way to
Vienna and he was a company Commander
and it was just survival attrition
like you know I'm sure he was a fine
Soldier but it was just attrition that
he went from Corporal to Captain and you
know a year or whatever
um
my grandmother's second husband
was a corpsman in the Navy so his story
is super funny
like he grew up in the small town on the
Columbia River in Washington State
so his I think there was like 20 dudes
in his graduating class in high school
and so they graduated June 1942.
so right after graduation like 201 like
every every male in his class went to
the recruiter and enlisted and so he
went in the Navy
um his Navy MOS was like a pharmacist
maid or something like that so he's like
oh I'll be on the ship like working in
the dispensary or whatever like wrong
like he graduates like they give him a
helmet and attach them to a marine
platoon infantry platoon and like you're
the medic and so he did like seven
amphibious assaults in the Pacific
like the crazy stuff right wow yeah like
it was super hard and he had amazing
Stories you know
um and then my my father's father was in
the Coast Guard and he did a lot of
coastal patrolling
um Oregon coast Washington coast
Columbia River during the war
um just you know looking for Japanese
subs or whatever
and so you because you had this sort of
Wanderlust that made you want to go
trekking the Himalayas and you have this
family that this background the military
you were thinking that this would be
something that would be adventurous or
intriguing to you yeah like I've always
I've always had a taste for like high
adventure like as a child like before
probably even before I was school so
like Saturday morning cartoons I got how
old are you 55 yeah we're same age so I
imagine probably grew up with similar
cultural influences so I remember in the
like mornings watching TV shows like
cartoons like Johnny Quest was the big
one right uh Speed Racer Marine boy like
all this you know Speed Racer Marine boy
we're we're anime but they were like
great you know Marine boy was basically
Speed Racer but underwater you know it's
just super cool Fantastical stuff
um great to feed the imagination like
the writing for Johnny Quest was so good
you know and like the show in in
retrospect was like kind of progressive
it's like Johnny had two dads and like
they had this like
um
multi-racial like composite family like
is like
but the writing was so solid like super
creative
um every I think it was only 26 episodes
but each episode is distinct and well
written and just just cool you know so
I would watch this as a kid and be like
I'm not sure what that is but I want to
do that
you know so that was kind of the initial
impetus for like and then growing up in
the woods in western Washington like
I was expected you know I was kicked
outside after breakfast and not expected
to be seen again until dinner time and
what I did between then was like on me
and so I'd go out and do stupid stuff
like climb high tension power lines you
know to the top like like five six years
old like so so stupid right but it was
like oh this is cool you know
um like in my mother
she definitely facilitated this stuff
like um
much to her credit
like we'd go camping uh in the Olympic
rainforest on the peninsula and there's
like a couple Rivers there but one of
the main ones is the ho River
and
I had this as a child I had like this
twenty dollar you know Kmart inflatable
raft with yours
and my mom would drive me up a river
like like 10 miles or 15 miles or
whatever in our Volkswagen bus and like
dropped me off me and my my 20 Kmart
boat
in a life vest and she'd be like all
right see you at the campground
and so I would be doing this like you
know white white water rafting by myself
in my in my cheesy little boat for
several several miles and you know
didn't drown obviously but it kind of
instilled again this it will reinforced
this sense of adventure you know
and I'm sure my mom would go to jail for
that today
you know probably not jail but yeah
definitely be discouraged
um
so that's background for the high
adventure thing the military thing
um
so 1993 I'm like okay
I I need to do something I need that
punctuated equilibrium right I need a
a dramatic event in order to promulgate
like the next period of growth or
Evolution or whatever so you really
actively thought that way yeah you were
trying to achieve growth yeah I didn't
want to stagnate I didn't want to
fall behind you know
um as
like I guess as soon as I figured out
what life authorship was or the concept
even though I made may have not have
known the term
yeah I kind of endeavored to actively
author my own life
um
um you know pursuing the ends of making
a life that kept me engaged kept me
interested
um and was was meaningful to me you know
so the military seemed like
like more and more like a viable option